In the previous video, we got
a feel for how regression trees
can do things linear
regression cannot.
But what really matters
at the end of the day
is whether it can predict things
better than linear regression.
And so let's try that right now.
We're going to try to
predict house prices using
all the variables we
have available to us.
So we'll load the
caTools library.
That will help us do
a split on the data.
We'll set the seed so our
results are reproducible.
And we'll say our split will
be on the Boston house prices
and we'll split it 70%
training, 30% test.
So our training data is a
subset of the Boston data
where the split is TRUE.
And the testing data is the
subset of the Boston data
where the split is FALSE.
OK, first of all, let's make
a linear regression model,
nice and easy.
It's a linear model
and the variables
are latitude, longitude, crime,
zoning, industry, whether it's
on the Charles River or not,
air pollution, rooms, age,
distance, another form
of distance, tax rates,
and the pupil-teacher ratio.
The data is training data.
OK, let's see what our
linear regression looks like.
So we see that the latitude
and longitude are not
significant for a linear
regression, which is perhaps
not surprising because
linear regression didn't seem
to be able to take
advantage of them.
Crime is very important.
The residential zoning
might be important.
Whether it's on
the Charles River
or not is a useful factor.
Air pollution does
seem to matter--
the coefficient is
negative, as you'd expect.
The average number of
rooms is significant.
The age is somewhat important.
Distance to centers
of employment (DIS),
is very important.
Distance to highways and
tax is somewhat important,
and the pupil-teacher ratio
is also very significant.
Some of these might
be correlated,
so we can't put too much stock
in necessarily interpreting
them directly, but
it's interesting.
The adjusted R squared is
0.65, which is pretty good.
So because it's kind
of hard to compare out
of sample accuracy
for regression,
we need to think of how
we're going to do that.
With classification, we just
say, this method got X% correct
and this method got Y% correct.
Well, since we're doing
continuous variables,
let's calculate the sum
of squared error, which
we discussed in the original
linear regression video.
So let's say the linear
regression's predictions are
predict(linreg, newdata=test)
and the linear regression sum
of squared errors is simply
the sum of the predicted values
versus the actual
values squared.
So let's see what that
number is-- 3,037.008.
OK, so you know what
we're interested to see
now is, can we beat this
using regression trees?
So let's build a tree.
The tree rpart command again.
Actually to save myself
from typing it all up again,
I'm going to go back to
the regression command
and just change "lm"
to "rpart" and change
"linreg" to "tree"--
much easier.
All right.
So we've built our tree--
let's have a look at it using
the "prp" command
from "rpart.plot."
And here we go.
So again, latitude and longitude
aren't really important
as far as the tree's concerned.
The rooms aren't the
most important split.
Pollution appears in there
twice, so it's, in some sense,
nonlinear on the
amount of pollution--
if it's greater than
a certain amount
or less than a certain amount,
it does different things.
Crime is in there,
age is in there.
Room appears three
times, actually-- sorry.
That's interesting.
So it's very nonlinear
on the number of rooms.
Things that were important
for the linear regression that
don't appear in ours
include pupil-teacher ratio.
The DIS variable doesn't appear
in our regression tree at all,
either.
So they're definitely
doing different things,
but how do they compare?
So we'll predict,
again, from a tree.
"tree.pred" is the prediction
of the tree on the new data.
And the tree sum
of squared errors
is the sum of the
tree's predictions
versus what they
really should be.
And then the moment
of truth-- 4,328.
So, simply put, regression
trees are not as good
as linear regression
for this problem.
What this says to us, given
what we saw with the latitude
and longitude, is that latitude
and longitude are nowhere near
as useful for
predicting, apparently,
as these other variables are.
That's just the way
it goes, I guess.
It's always nice when a
new method does better,
but there's no guarantee
that's going to happen.
We need a special structure
to really be useful.
Let's stop here with the R
and go back to the slides
and discuss how CP
works and then we'll
apply cross validation
to our tree.
And we'll see if maybe we
can improve in our results.